don't you guys miss working together on
saturday night live a little bit because
yeah you know i mean i know there was a
lot of pressure and stuff but getting to
do all those characters must have been
so great i missed the most
table reads on wednesday oh yeah that's
because that's the thing nobody else
gets to see right so you get to see
first you can see things that are going
to be hits in their early stages why is
bill laughing at the table room why
because that's your favorite thing too
it was but man when things would go bad
yeah so but i learned a lot actually
from watching fred because i was so i
lived and died by every sketch you know
and like what you said earlier i would
do something it would go bad and i would
go oh geez
and i remember i just want to crawl
under the table and die but i remember
watching fred and fred would be doing
something it wouldn't be going well and
he would just
be smiling and laughing and having such
a good time
i need to get to that place how do i get
it did you ever think something was
wrong with fred like he showed up
he was on another level
oh he's he's so confident
i remember
early on fred at the table read we
didn't do the sketch but you just played
a character kept putting a big winter
scarf oh yeah
did you ever make it on the air oh god
no
your idea for the sketch was a guy who
puts a winter scarf on yeah you know
when you come in from the cold and it
takes like a couple minutes to take this
like long hi everybody
i like this idea why would i hear about
these sketches that failed that they
they seem very funny that they should
have i mean you've seen this
that's only you you just had a five
second experience right yeah
when it's four minutes
like this we're like jesus four minutes
of you unwinding a scar you saw the
scarf come out at the table everybody
was like
in order to sell your idea you brought
in your prop which is your scarf
sometimes you do you can't do too much
of that you can't bring in everything
you brought in a typewriter for an elder
aide right yes yeah yeah what was the
typewriter sketch
a court reporter
you know those court people
yeah yeah so
the sound of it
and i'm such a i'm such a soft touch i
laugh very easily and if i was the judge
in those sketches and i was a judge
and i thought fred doing that just made
me laugh because he would do this thing
it would make me laugh and then on air
so you're me yeah he's on air and the
minute the camera would go to someone
else he would go
they come back to me and i have a smile
on my face and i'm like that court
reporter character i remember the first
time you did it uh there was the whole
court had to pause because
elinda nate could not her that the idea
that you have to give a [ __ ] you try to
you have to crack the other guy up or at
least these two i feel like
we did it on purpose a little bit the
other one that we did was fred wrote
this sketch that still makes me laugh
which was a short-term memory theater
right which was uh i was a doctor who
had worked with all these people with
short-term memory and i was going to do
a play with them and i acted in the play
and then i go and these people will not
forget a single line
and then i go i've worked with all of
them they will not get a single line out
of the gate it's like
honey how are you honey how are you you
know i'm having to prompt everybody
so in my head i went oh this will be
really funny and i go to john solomon a
writer i go give me something to say to
fred because he has to repeat whatever i
say no it's on air i'm going to mess
with him or whatever and it'll be fun
and fred had this sixth sense that i was
gonna do something and fred came into
the thing with what were you wearing
that's like a giants yeah that was a
giant's jacket
new york giants that made you laugh yeah
yeah and i go give me the jacket what
are you doing and you go and then you
give him a deck and you go is the play
over is it play over are we done is it
is the play over
no
[Laughter]
no now the play's not over and i'm like
there's another one that's online that
was cut from dress where you guys were
doormen oh we laughed so hard
christmas it was like a new york doorman
yeah
uh you were russian right bill yeah it
was russian i was like a spanish guy and
it was them talking to kids about
fred's telling a kid about rudolph do
you know the story of aerologo
christmas
there is a man named frosty snowman
frosty snowman what was that yeah that
was it yeah and it was it immediately
died
out there yeah it made it as far as
dress rehearsal yeah you two guys are
dormant and we were doing so bad that
bobby moynihan came out as a character
and we we and we went hey bobby moynihan
cause you knew it was hopeless it was
over yourself
what are you doing
and he went with it he's like hey guys
and he had like two teenagers so it's
like bobby has teenage daughters in life
and it was great but then the i think
the host was jamie foxx jamie foxx so
it's a really funny thing because the
sketch is bombing and so it's these guys
[ __ ] around and then they're messing
around with the other cast members and
then like a big movie star comes out and
you remember oh right yeah and you see
us kind of straighten up